[Music]
my memories of working at Senate live
are all about being there to like four
o'clock in the morning yeah and there's
this sort of special bond you have with
other people when you're just there all
the time
perfect example a buddy of mine Rob
Klein who's a writer on the show we left
probably about 5:00 a.m. after a writing
night and we live on the same block so
he shared a car home
and we got to his place it's before mine
on the block and he was like oh my gosh
I forgot my keys and I was like oh well
he's like I gotta go all the way back to
work all the way back to Midtown
it's like well you can just crash on my
couch if you want like it's not a big
deal he's like no I don't want to put
you out it's like really it's not a big
deal if you want it you can he's like
all right you know what that's actually
really nice I'll take you up on that
thank you I really appreciate it and
then right as we took a step off his
steps
this giant gay black man just kind of
appeared out from under his stairwell
and walked up to us and looked at us
both and just handed us a condom have
fun we were like no no and we realized
like nothing we said was gonna convince
him we weren't about to have sex yeah so
we're just like thank you thank you safe
sex angel of the West Village a mythical
magical creature yeah and we we were
like man that is such a funny story and
went back to my place and just went at
it like a couple of little rabbits
[Music]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography